This episode is sponsored by Nautilus.
Go to Nautil.us/microcosmos to
receive 15% off your membership.
Hello, and welcome.
You may have noticed that I am not one of
your regular hosts, and you are correct.
My name is Sarah Suta and you can
normally see me over at Bizarre Beasts,
but I heard that James, our master of microscopes,
had found something a little more macro
than usual and I wanted to take a look.
I actually spent a good number of years looking
through dissecting microscopes at everything
from beetles to mosquitos, and I'm excited to see
what he found at an even greater magnification.
Whenever we venture together
into the microscopic world,
as we often do on this channel, we never fail to
find both beauty and mystery in equal measure.
It's pretty much the only guarantee we have
when we point our microscope at a new sample.
We don't know exactly what we'll see, but we know
it will leave us enchanted and full of questions.
And the particular beautiful
mystery that we’re exploring
in this episode came to us via an unlikely source:
a gang of ruthless cats…
Let me explain.
See, a little while ago, James found
himself with a bit of a problem.
He was keeping some wheat grains at
home to use as food for the microbes
that he cultures and films for our enjoyment.
But before he could feed the grains to his
microbes, they became infested with the larvae..
of moths.
And while James worked to find the infestation,
his pet cats took it upon themselves to
deal with the situation in their own way.
What you’re looking at now, bursting
with color like the northern lights,
are the wing fragments of some moths
that were slain by James’s cats.
Because what does a microscopist
do when they find themselves with
an unexpected abundance of moth wings?
Well, you guessed it, they place
the fragments under a microscope
and attempt to reveal their secrets, of course.
But what could be that complex or enigmatic
about something as everyday as a moth wing?
It turns out, the wings of moths contain many
secrets that science has yet to fully explain.
Like, for example, the reason behind this
mesmerizing fluorescence unfolding in front of us.
After all, you would be forgiven for generally
thinking of moths as rather
drab, as far as insects go.
They’re not the most vibrant or
dazzling of critters to our eyes.
But it turns out that perception is more a result
of the limitations of our sight
than of their actual appearance.
Because, under ultraviolet light, the
wings of these moths glow like an aurora.
Both how and why this happens,
no one is honestly entirely sure.
Perhaps by exciting the wings
with high energy UV light,
their scales release fluorescent
particles into the water of the sample.
These particles absorb UV and re-emit the
energy as visible light in the form of
vivid greens and oranges, allowing us to glimpse
the hidden beauty and vibrant colouration that,
under normal circumstances,
would be totally invisible to us.
And, because the wing scales themselves
are hydrophobic by nature, the water
bursts with mists of fluorescent particles,
resulting in the waves of light we see here.
Another idea is that the wing scales
have some sort of innate UV reflection
or absorption properties, and what we’re
seeing are cones of light reflected by the
deforming nanostructures that are
responsible for those properties.
See, it might be surprising to learn
that the overlapping microscopic
wing scales of moths and butterflies are
actually one of their defining features.
Their scientific name - lepidoptera - is
a reflection of this characteristic trait,
it literally translates to ‘scaly wings’.
You might have even noticed this before,
if you’ve ever held a butterfly or moth,
they might have left behind
a fine powder on your hand.
That powder is made up of hundreds
or thousands of these wing scales,
which we’re looking at right
now at high magnification.
And the intricate, complex
nanostructures that line the
scales of their wings have been found
to have some interesting advantages.
For example, they play very strange
roles in their struggle for survival.
Some species possess elaborate nanostructures
on their scales that interact with sound,
rather than light, providing them with a
form of sophisticated acoustic camouflage.
For tens of millions of years, they’ve
been targeted by echolocating bats that
zero in on prey by bouncing
soundwaves off their bodies.
So, in response, the wing scales of
some moth species have evolved to
absorb these soundwaves, cloaking their
acoustic signature from unfriendly ears.
Perhaps the wing structures we’re looking at now,
which interact with light waves, also evolved
for a similar defensive role in this species,
scattering light as a means of visual camouflage
Or dazzling and obscuring the sight of potential
predators that can perceive certain wavelengths.
Though, unfortunately for these particular
moths, it clearly doesn't work against cats…
But predator avoidance is just
one of many possibilities.
Lepidoptera are an ancient and diverse
bunch, and their scaly wings are adapted
for a range of functions that we’re
only just beginning to understand.
Some seem to use their UV reflecting
wings not to hide or confuse,
but the total opposite - to communicate.
Like many other insect groups - but
unlike us - the eyes of lepidopterans
are exquisitely sensitive to the UV
part of the electromagnetic spectrum.
It’s the reason why researchers and
hobbyists will often collect them by
shining a UV blacklight against a sheet of fabric,
drawing in a range of species from far and wide.
And various lepidopterans are thought to
use their UV perception and manipulation
abilities to signal amongst each other
for mate attraction, species recognition,
and other secret messages we
can only guess the meaning of.
So maybe the aurora we’re gazing at is more like
fragments of a language that we can’t decipher,
brimming with information that
only other moths can comprehend.
But the truth is, we simply don’t know.
For now at least, the beautiful mystery
of this moth wing light-show
reveals just one clear message:
we still have so much left to learn.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Nautilus
for sponsoring this episode.
Nautilus is the science magazine that brings
the wonders of the universe to your fingertips.
In a world of complex ideas, Nautilus
simplifies science so everyone can understand.
And Nautilus explores a vast
array of captivating topics,
including art, anthropology,
geology. Physics, and more!
Renowned scientific minds and literary
giants alike contribute to Nautilus,
enriching its pages with their
expertise and creativity.
Whether you prefer a digital-only
membership or the print edition,
rest assured that you'll have full access
to all the wonders Nautilus has to offer.
But that's not all!
You'll also receive exclusive benefits
like priority access to events,
along with discounts on exclusive products.
You can become a member at the
url on the screen and embark on
a journey that will expand your
mind and ignite your curiosity.
Memberships to Nautilus seldom go on sale,
but if you go to Nautil.us/microcosmos right
now, you’ll receive 15% off your membership.
Those names you’re seeing on the screen
right now are some of our Patreon patrons,
and they are the reason that this show can exist.
If you’d like to join them in
supporting Journey To The Microcosmos,
you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro to
get weekly wallpapers and monthly uncut videos
If you’d like to see more from our
Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.